what can i play it's inspirational
i'll play knight six let's stay flexible
i can't i can't play budapest uh
i can play my main repertoire i'm just
thinking of like
some other idea let me play e6
and then if if c4 i'll play i'll play
some version of the mexican defense ooh
c3
so c3 signifies that white's maybe going
for a london
uh which would be pleasant
or even like uh what is it called a tori
let me see five if white goes for london
i'll probably be happy kingston
gifting a sub to cabba jewel
thanks kingston he's gifted 24 subs
oh e3 so white's building the hat
the infamous hat but blocking in this
bishop
so i i can't really take advantage of
this like positionally
there's no way to punish this i think
the best approach is just to continue
development
i have an idea i i i feel inspired
i feel inspired i'm actually i'm
actually slightly inspired by gotham
chess because i've seen him play
uh this sort of this sort of setup
but from the white side where
the idea is eventually like just shove
the g-pawn
and then checkmate move order might be
important and the fact that i'm down at
tempo might also be important
but let's start with queen c7 it's a
flexible move
non-committal yeah white wants to play
e4
so it might be now or never
g5
oh there's a funny line g5 takes and
then bishop g2
i started doing something very similar
earlier
i actually don't know if this works
because there's an f7
but yolo
at least white will think hopefully
i i want my bishop probably on d6 and
then
and two bishops like the battery it's
all about making the pieces work
together
i'm actually curious if this is like a
viable
approach i doubt there's there's too
many games in database like
because usually white will develop the
bishop e4
e4 unexpected but maybe playable
so i think i'm happy
i'd better be happy i didn't lose my
g-pawn
and now the knight pretty much has to
move
[Music]
and the question is like what to do
because white's controlling the center
uh there's a few ways to to try and tear
down the center
this move applies pressure d6 actually
looks attractive
just to play knight d7 and discourage e5
i could also take and then the knight c6
attacking the pawn
there is e5
if i take i sack a knight
just wondering if there's anything in
that line
one of the problems with with e5
is that if i move with a knight i lose
this pawn
so h5 might be a move
that's a question like h5 e5 here
i guess i'm threatening knight f4 there
there's my e4
[Music]
yeah let's play h5 i feel like this move
it's it's a move that i play anyway
eventually
and i'm not sure at least i wasn't sure
if i wanted to like commit to d6
okay so white has a clear idea offer's a
draw
i don't want to draw but white's writing
c4 oh
is that a threat i feel threat uh
slightly threatened
i have this move though take c4
knight b4906 king d8
looks okay
now this knight's solid so it's always
controlling the square
i always have the bishop to come in if
necessary
and this pawn is attacked
oh i'm playing a doctor
earlier pam was saying hi to talk to a
doctor in the chat
this is dr vladimir okay so trying to
complete development
i mean white's a bit
underdeveloped for the time being has to
deal with this pawn
ooh that's a very multi-purpose move
because white's defending the pawn
threatening to take an f6
and destroy me
first question can i do things against
the bishop
maybe but maybe not
i would love to take here the problem is
white takes
and then if i take knight f6
doesn't quite work
i can't play 97 because that just allows
too much
so i have this move which looks a bit
strange
but it does reinforce tonight
attacks the bishop might walk into b3
unleashes my bishop too
this is the most logical
it's getting spicy it's getting really
complicated
pocky penguin suggesting knight a5 so
the issue was uh was take some knight f6
so i want my knight on d5 to still
control f6
but this knight is very well placed
um but the one benefit for me
let's go for you wondering if roxy wants
a problem
it might be but might not be
let's play this so the one benefit of
the fact that white trade off
lightsweight bishop is that
this bishop is pretty much uncontested
so there's a lot of long-term potential
if i don't get crushed
in the center right away
the time being i'm still moderating this
these squares
white does have this move i would take
and then accept the fact the bishop can
plant itself
on f6 i'll probably want to trade off my
my dark sweet bishop at some point
i want to play knight f4 and attack but
white attacks me first
so probably bishop e7
it looks looks really ugly
oh maybe rook c8 first which i don't
know how useful rook c8 is
it's ninja's knight d3
suffering a little bit low on time
yeah let's play bishop bishop e7 i'll
take with king the king will
try and not get mated in the center
i saw a question about like studying
puzzles online i'm sure people in the
chat can can answer that
um i'm sure people in the chat are
familiar with like the the different
different websites
um oh chest tempo
chest tempo has very good reviews like
puzzle training
or like chess.com tactics trainer as
well
yeah so i mean white white can take and
plant a night here
and try and make me suffer i don't think
it's like so terrible
my pieces are are placed so light
doesn't do damage
and if ticks takes here i might even
have f6 or f5
in the meantime i'm still dreaming of
just like attacking
even like knight f4 knight h3
i guess 93 could come
also some idea h4
that's just a weird position
and we might get to a point where it's
like it's hard for either of us to break
through
the center is relatively close it's hard
to break through on the king's side
so this might actually call for like
slower play
like something something like rook g6 or
g8
king f8 just kind of chill
maybe queen b7
yeah so knight d3
i want to play this but
i should start with rook start with rook
g6
is there any threat
yeah it's just a better square for the
rook
okay
not sure how useful this this battery is
i mean the next step is improving the
queen
there's not too many options but i don't
want to be like pinned
my plays knight f4
probably have to take that
i'm wondering if i can play f5 here take
something king d8
looks really ugly because there's 96 on
that line
i um king d8 right away could play queen
this one's coming too
maybe queen b8
i'm just getting oh off the pin if i get
the chance i probably want to trade
i always have to consider f6 or f5
i feel like white's played a pretty good
game so far
just having hasn't given me too many
opportunities
but i'm still alive yeah f5 or six is
probably another threat because white
just takes with check
knight d6 comes
uh but this is probably most realistic
like if it's my move i take i play queen
eight
and maybe suffer a slightly worse end
game
another idea just to like run away with
the king
run and hide and if the king is on f8
then i can play f5 and
there's some pin so now on to son
okay i like the fact that white is
thinking here
i guess i should calculate 96.
and maybe f5 f5 takes rook takes
ooh knight f6 less expected
oh that attacks attacks a few things
have to move the rook
maybe to see it
that was a good move i'm wondering now
if i can
eventually play d6
best thing to do when the opponent
offers you a draw on your time is to
just let them think or offers you a draw
on their time the draw offer will still
be valid after white's move
i don't think i'm losing like completely
it's still very unpleasant
but this bishop is it's not to be messed
with
like if we can trade and i get a queen
to the what is this move
i take that
i can take oh queen b4
but then d6 oh but white trades rooks
first
[Music]
i think it's okay because i have queen
c5
it's complicated it was a very ambitious
move
so d6 oh the mover just doesn't quite
work for me though
i guess i have this move first
oh i just hung a wait this move no
i just hung a thing that was a really
bad move
that was a really bad move
i don't know what i could have done
though
okay let's just let's try and make this
somewhat of a fight
i probably should have accepted the
drama why probably just offered me a
draw in a winning position
wow what is this
oh that's clever so i can take
i'm gonna be down
down the rook down on time probably end
up losing this
the thing is white's taking a lot of
time here so there's some
some flagging potential
okay so what my king wants to cut to be
an active piece
all the pawns are kind of covered put
the king on e6
i play h4
all right it's hard to play f5
it's hard to put up a fight though given
the situation
i am trying
it's moving very slowly draw
wait i might flag him
dirty flagging coming oh i hung a rook
white hunger rook too
wow i went on time that was so unusual
i was really dirty oh i feel so dirty
dirty flag what was this
i'm probably just losing here my my
original thought i think
i think was g6 but the problem is takes
and they might just mates
i can't play king d8 because me d5 was a
really nice move
like this this could probably be in the
puzzle book
d5 the only winning move oh there's
everything's winning for lights but d5
is like the most
aesthetic like very clear-cut tactics
um
[Music]
yeah there's no defense
so i should have taken a draw
but also i made the right decision by
not taking a draw
because i went on time i mean my general
rule is like never accept draw offers
if there's any life even if you're
losing
because you learn more by playing on
yeah this is just a mess of the time
scramble
i guess maybe white white wasn't so
confident in the speed abilities
oh the one blunder
oh rook c8 is force mates made in four
yeah i got outplayed i wonder so i
wanted to check the database
in this position any games and masters
animes first of all
probably not
no some games here
oh queen c7 oh so bishop e7
so do any strong players go for like
some g5
yeah probably not not the right thing to
go for
um but it was it was fun
man me chest gives this move a question
mark
i mean chef should really check out my
g5 emote
oh a question from arizer chess
what is sent upon
yeah so when there's like computer
analysis in the on the game
um it will give a number for each side
the lower the center pawn loss the
better the play
so usually like a cent upon loss of 10
or lower is
like almost perfect play
um and it's basically
it's hard to explain i think there's an
faq on me chess
uh that better explains like it just
offers a better explanation than
i can provide um but yeah it's just a
number to indicate
how well you played i mean probably more
relevant are like number of blunders
mistakes etc
um i know chess.com they
they don't do center palm loss they do
like percent accuracy
which is maybe a bit easier to
understand